un nouveau défi layette de la comédie
après les sanctions américaines contre
l'iran
hassen de répond à marcher la politique
africaine de la france n'est pas né aux
colonies listes socialistes et
communistes dans les mairies une
coexistence difficile
madame monsieur bonsoir ce ne sont plus
seulement 50 diplomates qui sont retenus
en otage à téhéran mais 250 millions
d'américains qui se sentent
individuellement concernés et individus
en prisonnier des étudiants iraniens
une phrase que j'ai retenu entre autres
des déclarations d'hassan ii qui était
l'invitée d'antenne de midi au juge
et c'est sans doute l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles le président carter qui
joue sa place à la tête du pays a choisi
de frapper un grand coup en décidant la
nuit dernière de rompre toute relation
diplomatique avec l'iran et d'expulser
ses représentants aux états unis et
d'autre part de cesser toute activité
commerciale avec terre pour l'instant la
seule réaction iranienne et celle de
l'imam comme eni qui se félicite de
cette décision américaine qu'il
considère comme une preuve je le cite
que l'impérialisme américain et
désespèrent de washington notre
correspondant chaque cycle à washington
les stations locales fondu radioguidage
dont la grande avenue des ambassades la
massachusetts arrêt à la circulation
et dans moins de 11 heures à minuit et
quintuple aux mathes iraniens devront
avoir quitté washington une mesure
d'expulsion approuvé par l'opinion
publique qui attendaient depuis des
semaines un geste particulier de son
président l'ambassade d'iran et donc
isolé du reste de la ville et les
diplomates sont surveillés par les
agents du fbi haye qui veulent s'assurer
qu'aucun les représentants iraniens nord
à la tentation d'échapper à l'ordre
d'expulsion qui touche également les
consulats de new york chicago houston et
san francisco
aujourd'hui le chargé d'affaires et ses
collaborateurs pour leurs valises il ne
s'attendait pas à cette décision
monsieur ali agha chargé d'affaires donc
disait dans son dépit avoir été insulté
hier soir par le représentant américain
qui lui signifier la rupture des
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays
du côté américain
la dernière mesure de ce genre avaient
été prises en 1961 avec cuba à la maison
blanche on dit aujourd'hui on est entré
dans la troisième phase de cette crise
qui dure il mène depuis cent cinquante
sept chambres et il fallait bien apaiser
l'opinion publique
déçu et excité par une longue attente
avec guichet de mots il est encore trop
tôt pour savoir si carter est en train
de redresser la barre au moment
d'ailleurs où il reçoit anouar el sadate
pour un dossier lui aussi compliqué le
proche orient
mais au delà de ces préoccupations
électorales le président américain sait
que ses compatriotes sont à bout de
patience ils veulent leur otage
ils se sentent humiliés l'idée de la
force les démange l'opération militaire
qui désormais n'est pas exclue
consisterait à bloquer le détroit
d'ormuz ce blocus interdirait aux
tankers avec leur cargaison de pétrole
de faire route vers le japon où vers
l'europe qui serait pour un temps privé
en partie de leur pétrole quotidien et
la question des américains et celle ci
les européens sont ils prêts à pareils
sacrifices sont ils prêts à se montrer
solidaires de l'amérique
ici on en n'est pas tout à fait persuadé
oui les états unis pourraient bien
prendre d'autres sanctions c'est ce que
vient d'annoncer monsieur christopher
qui est le secrétaire d'état adjoint aux
états unis après avoir constaté les
effets produits par les premières qui
viennent donc d'être décidé en effet
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour dire que les décisions prises par
washington
noront véritablement de portée que si
elles sont relayées par les alliés de
l'amérique pire maritime la décision de
la maison blanche de rompre les
relations commerciales avec téhéran
représente davantage la concrétisation
officielle d'un fait déjà accompli
qu'une sanction économique
en fait les états unis ne commercent
pratiquement plus avec l'iran depuis
l'an dernier de 300 millions de dollars
par mois en 78 leurs exportations sont
tombées à moins de 2 millions par mois
dès la fin 79 en raison notamment du
blocage des comptes iranien dans les
banques américaines
côté énergie les américains depuis
plusieurs mois également se passe du
pétrole iranien
il consomme celui d'arabie saoudite du
venezuela ou même le leur mais ce
pétrole iranien existe toujours sur le
marché à la disposition des acheteurs
notamment européens les soubresauts de
la révolution islamique ont fait baisser
la production de moitié et la france qui
se fournissait naguère en iran à hauteur
de 8 % ne le fait plus aujourd'hui que
pour 3 ou 4% mais cela représente encore
plusieurs millions de tonnes davantage
encore pour les allemands et les
italiens
l'iran joue donc encore pour l'europe un
rôle de fournisseurs pétroliers amoindri
mais réelle alors qu'il n'est plus rien
pour les états unis
c'est une différence qui devra
certainement être prise en compte par
les européens pour débattre de
l'opportunité de suivre washington sur
le terrain des sanctions contre l'iran
et c'est sans doute aussi en pensant à
l'europe que le ministre du pétrole
iranien a déclaré cet après midi nous ne
vendrons plus de pétrole au pays qui se
montreraient hostile à la nation
iranienne
c'est un avertissement quel est son
poids pour la france
à peu près 5 millions de tonnes par an
oui je vous disais en commençant qu'il
n'y avait pas encore de réaction
officielle du côté iranien bien la
première vient de tomber à l'instant le
président iranien monsieur banny saab
appelé l'ensemble des iraniens à une
marche gigantesque à travers tout le
pays et cela dès vendredi proches
ainsi donc pour en revenir au sujet
parce que d'une part le président carter
fait appel à leur coopération et parce
que d'autre part les iraniens les
menaces de les priver de pétrole les
alliés des etats-unis et principalement
les européens dont les relations
économiques restent importantes avec
l'iran se retrouvent cette fois ci
obligé de prendre nettement position
paul n'a cette fois il semble bien que
les européens et les alliés des
etats-unis soit au pied du mur car
jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'europe s'était
contenté de soutenir mais verbalement
seulement les états unis
pour de nombreux pays européens dont la
france il n'est toujours pas question de
prendre des sanctions contre l'iran pour
au moins trois raisons la première les
intérêts politiques et économiques des
européens et des américains sont
différents deuxième raison les héros p1
ne veulent pas rompre tous les canaux de
communication avec téhéran troisième
raison enfin il faut protéger à tout
prix les ressortissants européens qui
séjournent encore en iran le
gouvernement iranien a si bien compris
les divisions du monde occidental qu'il
considère que même après les sanctions
américaines
aucun coup décisif ne peut être porté à
l'iran tant que les alliés des
etats-unis ne prendront pas une position
commune reste à savoir maintenant quelle
sera la prochaine décision la prochaine
étape que franchira le président
américain dans cette affaire des otages
qui constituent désormais véritablement
une bombe à retardement
non seulement pour les américains mais
aussi pour l'europe toute entière
oui pour le roi du maroc qui était
l'invitée d'antenne 2010 aujourd'hui les
sanctions prises par les états unis sont
inopportunes ce n'est pas dans tout cas
selon lui ce qu'il fallait faire pour
récupérer les otages
à propos duquel vous avez loi il s'est
montré très pessimiste n'en que le
processus est engagé vous faire tout ce
qu'il faut pour les sauver mais ça
m'étonnerait m'étonnerait qu'ils soient
récupérés
vous pensez que les 50 ou les 49
américains sont perdus erguy non mais je
doute qu'on les récupère t on demande il
à la politique de sanction du premier
dan carter a peut-être trop tarder elle
a été fragmentée et l'été harry bounce
été en dents de scie à mon avis les
décisions prises par le président carter
que je comprends pas bien
sont inopportunes à mon point de vue il
ne représente pas la thérapeutique ou si
j'avais été les états unis si j'avais eu
leur puissance l' affaire des otages
serait déjà terminée depuis fort long à
mon avantage ou pas je n'en sais rien
mais serait déjà terminée j'aurais
repris ma liberté d'action est
actuellement les états unis sont pieds
et poings liés
l'opinion publique ne pense qu'à ça même
là la campagne électorale se trouve
faussé à mon avis sur le plan du
jugement que nos portes et les lecteurs
sur son choix
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il reste
comme solution un shaker poussée de
savoir s'il voulait sauver ou sauver
l'amérique
s'il veut sauver l'amérique qu'elle sait
faire s'il veut les sauver
on lui demande une concession qu'il a
fait oui le roi hassan ii a encore
qualifié d'affabulations ce sont ses
propres termes les critiques formulées
contre la politique africaine de la
france le souverain a également déclaré
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'impression que la
france soit redevenu un pays
colonisateur les interventions de paris
en afrique at il ajouté ne sont pas plus
inopportune que celle de certains partis
communistes européens il faisait bien
sûr allusion aux déclarations de
monsieur georges marche
le président égyptien sadate est arrivé
aux etats unis c'est l'autre sujet de
préoccupation pour le président carter
monsieur sadate est venu pour essayer de
trouver une solution au problème de
l'autonomie palestinienne dans les
territoires occupés un problème qui
d'après les accords de camp david ou à
être réglé avant la fin du mois de mai
mais elle les discussions s'éternisent
et c'est pour cette raison que le
président égyptien est venus séparément
à washington discuté à son arrivée
monsieur sadate s'est montré confiant on
parle dans son entourage du un deuxième
discours qu'il pourrait prononcer devant
le parlement israélien
un geste spectaculaire pour essayer de
débloquer une nouvelle fois la
négociation
ce voyage intervient au lendemain de la
sanglante prise d'otages en israël un
attentat condamné par le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing
qui tiendra une conférence de presse
spécialement consacré à la politique
étrangère le 19 juin prochain
d'autre part c'est le 5 mai sur fr3 que
monsieur giscard d'estaing s'adressa aux
français dans le cadre de l'émission une
heure avec le président monsieur giscard
d'estaing il se trouvait jusqu'à ce soir
à courchevel
lula a rencontré aujourd'hui monseigneur
etchegaray le président de la conférence
épiscopale française avec lequel il a
évoqué la prochaine visite de jean paul
ii en france dix mille réfugiés cubains
dans les jardins de l'ambassade du pérou
à la havane ce chiffre est le dernier
indiqué par l' agence france-presse
un chiffre contesté par le correspondant
du journal l'humanité aujourd'hui qui
parle lui de 15 cents personnes en plus
c'est d'une opération montée de toutes
pièces contre le régime de monsieur
fidel castro au tchad quelques heures
avant le cessez-le-feu qui devait
intervenir en milieu de journée les
combats faisaient rage depuis aucune
autre dépêche n'est tombé pour dire si
oui ou non le cessez-le feu provisoire
était bel et bien observe en france le
parti socialiste publie aujourd'hui un
état des rapports entre les socialistes
et les communistes dans les
municipalités d'union de la gauche
cette publication intervient au
lendemain de la dernière crise ouverte
qui s'est soldé dimanche à brest par la
réélection du maire socialiste
ce document se présente comme un livret
scolaire avec des appréciations bonnes
ou mauvaises
le commentaire de noël copains la gauche
détient 155 des 220 villes de plus de 30
mille habitants
au total 390 ville de plus de 9000
habitants sont administrés soit par un
maire socialiste soit par un maire
communiste
le document du parti socialiste porte
sur 85 de ces villes le bilan apparaît
positif dans une large majorité d'entre
elles 70 dans 33 villes les relations
entre les deux partis de gauche sont
considérés par les socialistes comme
bonne elles sont même jugés excellents à
la rochelle très bonne à gray en
haute-saône ailleurs elles sont
satisfaisantes moyenne ou simplement
correcte
le bilan est négatif dans quinze
communes les rapports y apparaissent
très difficile difficile très moyen ou
moyen avec un refroidissement ces
dernières semaines ce document n'est
accompagnée d'aucun commentaire
politique mais voici comment jean
poperen voilà voilà situation pour le
parti socialiste
nous croyons pas une grave détérioration
dans l'ensemble en tout cas pour notre
part nous ne ferons rien en ce sens bien
au contraire
une somme pour tout ce qui favorisera
l'union des forces populaires
aujourd'hui comme hier mais il est
évident qu'il faut
pour vivre en commun le respect d'un
certain nombre de règles et permettez
moi d'ajouter que la campagne formidable
déchaînés depuis hier sur cet acte
normal démocratique de la majorité
socialiste de brest bat fait
malheureusement partie de cette campagne
générale depuis des mois du parti
communiste tout entière tournée contre
le parti socialiste le parti communiste
à partir de l'exemple récent de brest
fait toujours reposer la responsabilité
des ruptures sur le parti socialiste
mais il souhaite que l'union soit
maintenue nous pensons qu'il s'agit là
de la mise en cause des accords
municipaux passé en 1977 qui sont la
conséquence de la stratégie politique du
parti socialiste qui a commencé par
considérer le programme commun comme un
carcan et qui considèrent aujourd'hui il
n'y super tu es d'union comme des
carcans on veut qu'à si l'union au
niveau municipal
aujourd'hui les socialistes sont un
bilan plutôt satisfaisant de trois ans
de gestion
quel serait votre bilan bien je dirais
d'abord que si une partie socialiste
déclare de telles choses chez pour que
cacher justement ces pratiques des
maires socialistes et à notre avis ce
bilan aurait dû être positive partout
élu en 1977 les municipalités sont à la
moitié de leur parcours prochaines
élections 1983 ce sera aussi en principe
l'année des élections législatives d'ici
là il lui a roulé présidentielle le sort
des municipalités de gauche dépendra
beaucoup du climat de ces consultations
nationales
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de paris examinera le 26 avril
prochain le dossier de la sphère de
breuil et fixera en même temps la date
du procès renaissent parallèlement elle
étudiera la demande de supplément
d'information déposée par la famille de
la victime
après les révélations du canard enchaîné
aujourd'hui on attendait de nouveaux
développements dans cette affaire sur
place au palais de justice françois camp
on attendait aujourd'hui au palais de
justice de paris des éclaircissements du
juge floch chargé en son temps de
l'instruction de la sphère de breuil sur
les confidences verbal que lui aurait
faite gens du cru au moment des faits le
directeur de la police judiciaire va ce
soir on est un peu déçu en fait
guy floch n'a pas dit grand chose il a
simplement dit qu'il avait des règles de
déclaration à faire mais qu'il l'ait
réservé au magistrat instructeur si la
chambre d'accusation décidé un
supplément d'information dans la suite
de cet appel
il ya peut-être une phrase qui en dit
long
car il faut savoir lire entre les lignes
le juge bloc a dit qu'il avait suivi
avec beaucoup d'intérêt et avec beaucoup
d'attention les déclarations des uns et
des autres est en fait il semble que le
juge bloc ne soit pas du tout d'accord
avec monsieur d'ukraine alors est ce que
oui ou non monsieur ducale n'avait pas
tenu il faudra attendre pour un ça va
quant à michel poniatowski le ministre
de l'intérieur à l'époque des faits il a
déclaré aujourd'hui qu'il n'avait pas
été tenu au courant de cet après les
jeux mais ni vu ni lu un document une
note une information et hop une autre
nation n'a été porté à ma connaissance
dont ce domaine oui un certain nombre de
questions qui sont posées actuellement
dans la presse on parle notamment de vos
relations avec lâcher de broyer ce que
vous l'avez rencontrée dans les semaines
dans les mois qui ont précédé sa mort de
les 176 alors prenons j'étais ministre
de la santé de la sécurité sociale le
ministre d'état et de l'intérieur se
tient pendant plus de quatre ans je n'ai
jamais rencontré monsieur de brouille
qu'une seule froid je crois bien que
c'était fin 1975 où il est venu me
demander une subvention pour un village
de sa circonscription
en dehors de cela je vais jamais on
compte alors cette affaire le spar
entraîne un espèce de montage politique
et on va essayer de faire croire que
j'ai rencontré michel breil à dîner au
mois de décembre 1976 on va même précisé
qu'il ya quelques jours avant samarie on
a même précisé que j'étais au château de
breuil le 8 décembre
la mine et des archives ceci est
totalement absolument est intégralement
faut le groupe action directe revendique
aujourd'hui le sabotage des ordinateurs
de la société philips de toulouse c'est
par un message téléphonique à l'agencé
france presse que le groupe a fait cette
annonce 48 heures après l'attentât
pierre fouque
c'est dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
que les saboteurs ont opéré brûlant les
programmes d'ordinateur et les fiches
magnétique et endommageant certaines
pièces des appareils un travail de
professionnel selon directeur de la
société
ce matin le sabotage été revendiquée par
le groupe action directe par téléphone à
l afp ce que nous avons découvert dans
les locaux de philips informatiques
étaient destinés à la défense nationale
et ouzbeks et sera divulgué
prochainement et publiquement dans les
jours qui vont suivre précise le
communiqué ajoutant que le groupe
signera désormais action directe des 27
et 28 mars 1980 et que l'organisation
n'en restera pas là
après le coup de filet du 28 mars 15 des
19 personnes arrêtées ont été inculpés
par le juge d'instruction à la cour de
sûreté de l'état d' attentats par
explosifs tentative d'honneur et
association de malfaiteurs
ces chefs d'accusation sont pas relation
avec une entreprise consistant ou
tendant à substituer une autorité
illégale à l'autorité de l'état par
leurs récentes actions le groupe prouve
est donc sa possibilité d'agir malgré
les arrestations du 28 mars dernier vous
venez de l'entendre ce soir la cour de
sûreté de l'état a été saisie du dossier
de cette affaire de cet attentat de
samedi à toulouse le cnpf est favorable
à une participation des cadres au
conseil d'administration c'est une des
phrases à retenir de l'interview de
monsieur ceyrac au quotidien rhône alpes
qui doit sortir demain j'essaierai qui
est également favorable au développement
de l'actionnariat dans l'entreprise
développement qui va être discuté par
les députés
très prochainement à l'occasion de cette
session de printemps 12 millions de
devises et de bijoux c'est le butin du
cambriolage de l'hôtel cannes palace à
cannes justement la nuit dernière les
voleurs ont tout simplement profitant de
l'obscurité remporter les 25 offres dans
lesquels étaient déposés
l'argent et les valeurs des clients de
l'hôtel il y avait du monde ce week end
en bretagne ce qui ne veut pas dire que
la saison touristique sera bonne
car si certains étaient venus parce
qu'il faisait beau d'autres étaient
simplement là par curiosité pour
constater les dégâts de la marée noire
enfin les derniers avaient
malheureusement fait le déplacement pour
annuler leurs réservations de l'été
parfois la foule parfois seulement le
vent influences très diverses selon les
secteurs pour cette pac noir de la côte
de granit rose et dans certaines rues
embouteillées dans certains restaurants
pendant trois jours on a même retrouvé
la cohue des week-end pascal des années
60 mais en fait deux séjours les
amoureux les estivants et les habitants
de la bretagne étaient venus parfois de
fort loin pour constater l'épaisseur et
l'étendue des dégâts
ce pèlerinage était donc autant de la
curiosité que de la solidarité avec les
sinistrés de trégastel et de ploumanac'h
rebaptisé au goudron très gasoil et plus
mazout
côté hôtellerie et restauration la
situation n'est pas brillante malgré les
apparences de ce dernier week end
si quelques réservations supplémentaires
sont enregistrées on commence à noter
les annulations de location pour cet été
comme après la moco cadix pour
l'immédiat certains professionnels du
tourisme considère déjà ce printemps
comme une saison complètement ratée et
1980 sera une année catastrophe
si le décor n'est pas à nouveau breton
au moins en juillet
guerre des vignobles en champagne en
effet dans cette région strictement
délimité le moindre espace exploitable
et mises en valeur à tel point qu'un
exploitant qui veut s'agrandir pour
installer ses enfants par exemple
n'arrive pas à trouver un seul mètre
carré j'exagère à peine le marché
foncier étant pratiquement nulle les
prix sont donc en train de s'emballer
pour ne pas dire explosé au cours actuel
un hectare dix mille mètres carrés peut
atteindre 2 millions de francs une
enquête de bernard mac
cet homme travaille huit heures sous
terre comme dans une mine et la
champagne en effet est une mine d'or
184 millions de ces bouteilles ont été
vendues en 1979 valeurs plus de 5
milliards de francs lourd soit
l'équivalent du budget de la jeunesse et
des sports plus celui de la recherche
scientifique à la base de ce pactole un
vignoble champenois étriqué plus petit
que celui de la corse et de la champagne
est due à une politique de qualité de
prestige d'une organisation très
poussées entre le vignoble de négoce qui
est essentielle et elle ce puits
absolument sur une loi foncière qui va
loin de 1927
cette loi des limites de
individuellement tous les terrains qui
sont susceptibles d'être plantés en
vigne appellation champagne
il ya actuellement 24 1300 hectares
plantés il aurait à peine 5000 hectares
plantés par conséquent nous arrivons à
la fin nous voyons la fin de l'extension
du vignoble champenois et en conséquence
les prix des terres à vignes ou des
vignes eux-mêmes connaissent un
emballement et les prix le sort action
pas justifiées sur le plan économique
ceux qui ont des vignes les gardes saute
en cas de force majeure c'est rare c'est
donc cher même si la safer société
d'aménagement foncier qui a priorité
d'achat a le pouvoir d'imposer un prix
plus raisonnable
la safer contrôle pour l'ensemble très
bien le marché les prix sont dix ans
variable suivant les crues
ici nous sommes dans les temps les
grands crus donc il y à des prix qui
sont même plus cotés du coin jfd les
prix normaux se situe autour de 800
mille neuf cent mille suivant l'état des
vignes suivant le lieu dit si vous
voulez 90 millions anciens de oui oui
alors que les prix moyens en champagne
il ressort d'une étude que nous avons
fait en cinq ans 79 à la safer le prix
moyen doit ressortir à 410 mille francs
au niveau de global champagne c'est un
viticulteur
on contrôle les prix déclaré mais il ya
des dessous de table et de plus dans le
cas d'une vente judiciaire
la safer perd ses droits alors ça peut
devenir un stratagème fructueux c'est
très simple imaginez que vous ayez une
parcelle de vigne
vous souhaitez en sortir le bon prix eh
bien vous me vendent et non pas quelques
ares de votre vie telle ou telle partie
de la parcelle
mais vous me vendée la moitié des droits
indivis sur cette parcelle c'est à dire
quelque chose qui n'est pas matériel on
s'entend bien vous les vendez et
quelques années après il se trouve en
restant très bons amis qu'on ne
s'entendent plus et que fait-on vous
savez très bien que nous n'est tenu de
rester dans l'indivision
or dans ces cas là c'est très simple on
demande la vente judiciaire et la safer
n'a plus qu'un droit celui de racheter à
prix égal c'est à dire hors de prix et
donc elle renonce et c'est une vente
judiciaire tout à fait normale celle là
qui a permis récemment d'adjuger une
parcelle de 15 ares 68/100 siar pour 265
mille francs en y ajoutant les frais
légaux cela fait une valeur à l'hectare
de deux millions deux cents millions de
centimes
même pour un grand cru la somme a paru
extravagante dans la nuit une partie de
la vigne a été saboté à coups de
sécateurs alors encore à nuits polaires
pour couper toute sorte victime de la
grogne de ses voisins l'acheteur un
vigneron de cramant avait accepté le
prix fort pour installer son fils il n'y
avait pas d'autres moyens
les saboteurs voilà qu'il fait couper
par bonheur c'est une fête et oublier
des saboteurs qui a restauré sa beauté
qu'est ce que vous en pensez du sabotage
qui a eu lieu dans la ville de monsieur
boulaire brasser un saboteur chez port
d'inr mais c'est la limite des prix
c'est 100 et les gens qui veulent tous
en selle soit bon du crochet et ça c'est
pas parce que c'est monsieur voulait
sort a été monsieur une scic ou monsieur
at-elle saraka fait exactement pareil
est ce qui compte c'est pour les
successions les gens sont morts
on est toujours en train de faire des
donations c'était le prix après c'est
l'enregistrement qui vient vous emmerdez
alors autorisé l'extension du vignoble
éclaircirait peut-être l'avenir en
champagne même si pour le moment ça
tourne sport vous allez le voir sur ces
images c'est un équipier de bernard
hinault raymond villemiane qui a gagné
la traditionnelle course cycliste
professionnel paris vimoutiers autrement
dit paris camembert nous allons voir sur
ces images
l'arrivée de cette course et donc la
victoire de raymond villemiane équipier
le bernard hinault qui gagne au sprint
voilà l'image traditionnelle du
vainqueur ce soir
en football journée de championnat en
première division avec les résultats
dans notre dernier journal mais surtout
demain en direct sur antenne 2 c'est sûr
coupe d'europe des vainqueurs de coupes
nantes valence si les deux équipes se
connaissent mal en revanche leur
entraîneur se connaissent bien
di stefano l'entraîneur espagnol et jean
vincent l'entraîneur nantais ont joué
l'un contre l'autre en finale de la
coupe d'europe lorsqu'il opérait
respectivement au real madrid et à serge
richet nous présente l'équipe de valence
qui rencontrent demain à nantes
glasgow rangers battus 3 1 sur son
terrain barcelone tenant de la coupe des
coupes
éliminés ce sont les deux grandes
victimes de l'appétit européen du fc
valence 1980 quatrième du championnat
d'espagne mais exclu de la course au
titre national ainsi que de la coupe
valence l'un des clubs les plus riches
et les plus puissants d'espagne ne pense
plus qu'à l'europe valence est avant
toute chose un entraîneur prestigieux di
stéfano six fois vainqueur de la coupe
d'europe des clubs avec le real de
madrid
il disposera pour affronter nantes de
joueurs de talent trois membres de
l'équipe nationale espagnole qu'arrêter
solsona saura et surtout bien sûr de
super vedettes du football mondial
l'international reiner braun of
champions du monde il y a 6 ans avec
l'allemagne un terrible pied gauche
l'un des plus beaux tee du monde mario
kempès lui vainqueur de la coupe du
monde en 1978 avec l'argentine et kempès
méfie de nantes car il se souvient de
l'équipe de france à buenos aires s et
hongrie et
elle a conduit les avons joué d'abord
contre la hongrie qui nous a posé pas
mal de problèmes mais c'est sans aucune
mesure avec ce que nous avons
rencontrées face à la france je garde un
souvenir très douloureux de cette
rencontre difficile aux nantais
d'entretenir de m'asseoir les styles
août et kong mario kempès pour le
football français
oui demain soir une soirée à éviter pour
les cardiaques je pense que ça va être
assez dur
la météo pour terminer demain mercredi
sur l'est des ardennes l'alsace jura la
savoie et le lyonnais
le temps sera très nuageux à couvert
avec des averses de pluie et de neige au
dessus de 600 à 800 m sur les autres
régions
des nuages alterneront avec de belles
éclaircies surtout près de l'atlantique
et de la méditerranée
vent de nord faible à modéré fort dans
la vallée du rhône et près et en
provence températures assez basses pour
la saison
voilà c'était un beau week-end on a rien
à regretter dernier journal en fin de
programme avec hervé claude main invités
d'antenne 2010 simone signoret demain
soir le match de football et je retrouve
à 20 heures bonsoir excellente soirée
sur antenne 2